if you're watching this video you
probably know somebody that filed a
bankruptcy because of medical bills
which by the way out of all the
bankruptcies done in America 66 and a
half percent of all the bankruptcies are
due to medical bills according to
American Journal of Public Health that's
a lot of bankruptcies and by the way out
of those people that file bankruptcies
72 percent of the time they had health
insurance so wait a minute do you have
health insurance how did you file
bankruptcy how do these guys make money
what is this health insurance business
why do so few people trust it how do
hospitals make money how much do they
charge what is their profit margin who's
being held accountable are health
insurance companies making the money and
saying good for you I already got my
money your problem is the government not
collecting money is the hospital not
getting the money for anybody but who's
paying for all this stuff and at the
same time all the politicians don't want
to talk about Medicare Medicaid let
alone Social Security because God forbid
if they say the right thing to do is we
kind of got to get away with this stuff
they're not going to get reelected so
they want to keep getting reelected so
they keep saying you cannot do this it's
not fair but guess what at whose cost at
whose experience at gen Z's at
Millennial at Gen X so these guys are
probably never going to get any of this
stuff but they finance it for them why
is that fair these are a lot of great
questions we're going to talk about that
today all right so if you give out yet
in this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel but let's get
right into it let me ask you a question
have you ever gotten a speeding ticket
and you don't have any money you're
broke I remember when this would happen
to me you don't know how you're going to
pay for the speeding ticket and many
times I didn't pay for it and I have to
pay for it six months later and I would
get pulled over and the cop would say
get out of the car you have six tickets
you haven't paid for I've been through
this before now let me fast forward when
you're 32 years old 48 years old 57
years old you take your kid to the
hospital you're about to go to the
hospital and you know a bill is coming
your way you just don't know how much
it's going to be do you do they tell you
this is how much your bill is gonna
nobody tells you that and that's what
they call a surprise medical bill and
you're sitting there saying man I have
no idea what it's going to be here's a
number for you 41 of insured adults have
surprise medical bills and two-thirds of
them are worried about being able to
afford that surprise medical bill you've
been there I've been there before or how
many people are going through this but
where's the profit margins in this how
are people paying for these let me give
you some more statistics here 78 of
adults have avoided hospital visits 44
Medical Care due to the cost have you
ever no you're sick you know something's
wrong with you you know you don't know
what's going on with your chest pains
your back pain here you do not want to
go because you don't want that bill you
don't know if you can afford it but many
times you have health insurance and
you're still not going so why do we have
health insurance why are we paying for
it if we do have it do you know how many
people are asking these questions so
let's continue 30 said they have to
choose between paying for medical bills
or basic necessities like food or
housing meaning you have a choice to go
to the doctor and pay for that bill
versus man I got to get some food for
the kids and paying for my rent you know
which one I want to choose I'll tolerate
the pain I'm going this way have you
done that before maybe you haven't well
your parents may have done this before
and this continues 137 million people in
U.S reported struggling with medical
bills let me say the number again to you
137 million people here's another one
for you you ever gone to the hospital
like oh you got to stay for three nights
you're like no I'm good listen man your
leg is broken you got to sit here for no
no no no no I'll go walk on a crutch do
you want to no no no leave it alone
because I know everything is an add-on
and a cost but do you know how much it
costs to stay at a hospital do you
actually know the numbers you want to
learn about it if you don't want to
learn about it skip this part and go
watch something else because I'm going
to show you how much these things cost
look life is pretty complicated
sometimes sometimes you're dealing with
something with divorce you know you're
going through some you lost a loved one
you're about to get fired you don't know
what's going on data came out saying one
in four Americans don't have anybody to
confide in this is why today's sponsor
better help is here to help you and this
is what they do you have a list of 20
000 plus therapists who talked about
whatever issues you want and you
literally answer a questionnaire that
identify a few options you speak to them
on your phone in a zoom on your computer
by yourself you have somebody to confide
in and if you don't like it they'll
replace it with another person at no
additional charge so meaning if it
didn't work out they'll help you out but
look as a person that's been running a
lot of businesses for many years I I
need to talk to some people I can't talk
to my wife all the time or my friend
friends some things I want to talk to
somebody else that maybe is not even
connected to me this would have been the
perfect app for me to use betterhelp.com
forward slash valuetainment if you go
there right now you'll get 10 off your
first month or you can click on a link
below in description to go to
betterhelp.com forward slash
valuetainment here we go nationally U.S
hospitals charge
417 dollars for every 100 of their costs
which means their net cost is a hundred
dollars they're going to charge you for
17. the 100 most expensive U.S hospitals
charge ready between 11 29 to 1808 per
hundred dollars of their cost 1808 is
1800 percent of their cost and you know
what their answer is because they can so
you may say Pat give it a break what's
been the history with this let me show
you it's been in 1999 it was only 200
per 100 but it's gone up every single
year all the way up to the data we have
here is 417 percent as of 10 2018 and
you know after colbit those numbers went
even higher this next chart is also a
little bit concerning because you know
we did a couple videos in the past one
of them being like you know you want to
be able to have more Regional Banks why
there's more competition right you want
to have more Community Banks because
it's more competition and right now a
lot of these signature Banks a lot of
these banks that are going out of
business and the bigger banks are
picking it up gradually we're going from
having a lot of different options to
having a few different options and what
happens when we have a few different
options they get to dictate the price of
whatever they want to do the same thing
is happening with weapons of mass
destruction where you're hearing a lot
of these big companies that would make
weapons they make planes they make tanks
it used to be so many of them it's now
gone down to only a handful of them so
they have the mark they have control and
they're kind of working together to
dictate what everybody else has to pay
for watch this when you look at this
chart from 94 to 2018 in 1994 only 37
percent of the hospitals in America
belong to a system meaning a controlled
Consolidated multi-hospital system 37 so
the other 63 percent was was
independently owned by a lot of
different people so the 37 percent
couldn't push their weight around
because they had a lot of other people
that were competition well today that 37
percent is now 67 percent which is
collectively being done by a few
different people so they dictate
whatever the terms are for the price of
these hospitals that's why they can
increase their rates because they
control the market so I want to give you
an example of some of these hospitals on
what they're charging per hundred
dollars here's what you will look at
number one would be Capital Health which
is based out of New Jersey 1443 percent
number two is care Point Health which is
in Florida and Jersey thirteen hundred
thirteen percent third one is Regional
Medical Center which is 1106 out of
Florida fourth one is American academic
Health System uh 1064 percent out of
Pennsylvania then you got Temple
University a thousand percent out of
Pennsylvania again then he got HCA out
of Florida then you got tenet Healthcare
Corporation out of Texas then you got
Community Health Systems which is
National then again Universal Health
Services which is National you got St
Luke's out of Pennsylvania 300 of the
top 10 was Pennsylvania and three out of
the top ten was Florida now you may ask
why Pennsylvania and Florida in the top
10 because Florida is in the top five
oldest states in America population wise
and Pennsylvania is a top eight all the
state population wise in America so they
have older peoples that are like listen
guys we got a lot of Boomers here
charging up Mark it up a little bit
we're gonna make some money here because
again they can now some of you may be
watching the same Pat if I can't pay the
bill I can't pay the bill I just don't
pay the bill that's what I do well you
know there's many ways they can get the
money from you one of them being wage
garnishment they can in many cases up to
25 percent it can just take the money
out of your account if they really
wanted to these people can file for it
and that can happen obviously some
states are more strict than others but
there is another part to this on a
hospital being interviewed on why these
prices are going higher what is the
regulation who's controlling them and
this was done by Dr Marty McCary and
here's what he came up with in a book he
wrote titled the price we pay
researchers from the University of Iowa
called the 101 U.S hospitals on prices
from the same type of heart bypass
operation only 53 provided the price
varied from forty four thousand dollars
to four hundred forty eight thousand
dollars so 101 hospitals 53 gave the
rate from 44 000 to 448 my dad has had a
bypass what what's the difference one is
44 one is 440 that's ten times more who
dictates the terms do I just pick and
choose and say yeah I think you look
like a 300 000 type of person now I
think you're 80. let's leave for 220 who
determines what these prices are is it a
secret can we no can you imagine you go
buy a car is I'd like to buy that
Mustang what's the price can't tell you
until you buy it what's the price of the
car nope you want to buy it yes 78 000
it's really twenty two thousand dollars
imagine how weird that is that's how
hospitals work he continues Hospital
officials confessed that they inflate
bills each year in order to generate
more Revenue since the insurance
companies pay only part of the sticker
prices Insurance confess they demand
bigger and bigger discounts in their
contracts with hospitals in order to
keep up both admitted that they pass on
higher bills to the public in the form
of higher insurance premiums and last
but not least watch what this lady said
at the end just flat out a Hospital
employee whom Dr Marty McCary confronted
on behalf of a patient who received an
exorbitant hospital bill provides the
answer the law allows us to charge
whatever we want if we want to charge a
million dollars she has to pay for it
can you imagine that so it's already
crazy enough but this next stat I share
with you some of you guys are going to
say I don't believe this you're going to
have to go do your own research when I
show you this number can you tell me
what are the biggest industries in
America by Revenue by Revenue you ready
the number one industry in America by
revenue and this is numbers from 2023
hospitals in the U.S is number one
1.426 billion dollars number two is drug
in cosmetic and toiletry wholesaling in
the U.S 1.364 then you get
pharmaceutical wholesaling then health
and medical then Commercial Banking then
new car dealers then life insurance and
annuities hospitals is number one and no
one even talks about it however here's
the crazy part about hospitals if I were
to ask you how much money do these guys
make man on 1.426 the margins got to be
massive like this Google Facebook ad
it's got to be massive margins that's
the problem their margins are very small
but how matter of fact if you look at
the numbers in 2022 and early 2023 you
will notice according to Kaufman Hall
operating margin index year to date by
month they're in the negative look at
the numbers right there well negative
2.1 negative 2.4 negative 1.9 negative
negative every month has been in the
negative and even if we go prior to
coven and maybe we go look at 1995
through 2016. it's always been in the
single digits the lowest was two percent
and the highest is roughly eight percent
so how how is this even possible you you
got 400 percent to eighteen hundred
percent of margins shouldn't you be
making more money I don't even
understand how this is possible here's
why because the government is heavily
involved when you look at Medicare and
Medicaid in 2020 combined on
underpayments not payments but
underpayments where a hundred billion
dollars up from 75.8 billion dollars in
2019 and the 2020 underpayments includes
a shortfall of 75.6 billion for Medicare
and 24.8 billion for Medicaid A matter
of fact for Medicare hospitals receive
payments of only 84 cents for every
dollar spent by hospitals caring for
Medicare patients in 2020. now this
doesn't include increased labor
increased medicine 18 billion dollars
just for illegal immigrants in 2018
according to Forbes that we can add on a
bunch of different things and you know
the numbers keep adding up so you
realize they're not making any of the
money as much as I thought they would be
making but who's not doing their part is
it the health insurance company are they
taking the money on leaving is it the
government taxpayers maybe they're
expecting us to pay a lot more whose
fault is it that this is taking place
remember earlier I talked about Medicare
Medicaid where generation is holding
everybody else hostage for making sure
that they get their social security
Medicaid Medicaid the Baby Boomers a lot
of people are going to get get upset at
this but I'm not running for office I'm
not trying to get reelected I'm not a
governor I'm not a congressman I'm not a
senator I'm not a president I'm not
trying to win your vote my job is to ask
questions and saying can we afford it
every year we keep getting into more and
more debt what's the solution not a
worry keep kicking this debt to the Next
Generation let them handle it let their
grandkids handle it let our kids handle
it who cares about them let's take care
of our lives right now they'll figure
out a way they're young they're going to
be old one day and what are they going
to do do exactly what you did and then
eventually this great idea called United
States of America poof is gone and hey
another person comes in we're in debt
now people are leaving to other
countries oh it'll never happen to
America maybe to Rome maybe to the
Persian Empire maybe to agree maybe but
not not in America not never not here no
we're headed in that direction with
these irresponsible decisions that we're
making and by the way let me continue
watch this the national Healthcare
anti-fraud Association nhcaa estimates
that the financial losses due to a
health care fraud might be as high as
300 billion dollars each year this is on
top of everything else but watch this
data of how far along we've come since
1960s National per Capitol Health
expenditure in the U.S from 1960 to
today so if you look at it right there
in 1960 it's a hundred and forty six
dollars per person in expenditure to now
it's gone all the way up to twelve
thousand five ninety one how long can we
afford this by the way with an aging
population matter of fact in September
of 2020 president Donald Trump signed an
executive order aimed at Insurance
Hospital price transparency and limiting
surprise billing requiring that price
information he made publicly available
this was obviously a great piece of
legislation because it would give people
the ability to compare prices and force
hospitals to price operations more
competitively it's like saying hey what
do you charge for this car twenty eight
thousand dollars Galpin Ford sells it
for 24. hey guys the other guy sells it
for 24. match them we'll sell it to you
for twenty four thousand dollars see
what happened but before you couldn't
compare it so Trump says I think we
ought to do this and guess who says we
ought to continue with this so Biden
directed the Department of Health and
Human Services to enforce the rule which
what Trump started is like yeah it's
kind of a good idea we got to do but
watch what happens only a year later a
research published by non-profit Group
Patient rights Advocate determined that
471 out of 500 hospitals examined were
not in compliance with the new rule and
at the same time the maximum fine from
the federal government for failing to
post prices is 109 500 per year even
though CMS said in July that they were
planning on raising it to 2 million per
year for large hospitals the problem is
they send warning letters to almost 170
hospitals that had yet to post prices
but the agency had an imposed any fines
and Catherine Howden a spokesperson for
CMS said that the agency expects
hospitals to comply with these legal
requirements and will enforce these
rules if the hospitals don't comply
within 90 days you know what they do
they send you a warning letter that's it
you get another warning letter can you
imagine it's like a love letter on top
of Love Letter and nothing else happens
and in May of 2023 some data came out
ways and means committee chairman Jason
Smith brought the fact citing that fewer
than one in four hospitals are estimated
to be in compliance with these price
transparency rules and only for
hospitals out of six thousand Nationwide
have been fined for non-compliance so
guess what hospitals I get out of here
you're not going to do anything we're
giving you money anyways when you're
getting reelected you need our money you
need us to keep charging more money so
we can give you more to your campaign
and we'll hire the lobbyists to come and
help you out don't act like you care say
it from stage but you know you're not
going to enforce it behind closed doors
that's kind of what's happening I got
the one last thing I'm going to show you
this one's going to probably upset you
the most on how we can afford to do this
kind of stuff so watch us here's an
article from American Hospital
Association look what it says Medicare
and Medicaid pay less than cost the
owners should pay little or nothing and
others must make up the difference I'm
going to read it to you one more time
Medicare and Medicaid pay less than what
it costs
so hospitals who are getting money for
Medicaid Medicaid they're not getting
what it costs them they're getting paid
less the uninsured paying literal to
nothing the uninsured those are like I
can't afford health insurance the ones
that are not being responsible having
insurance or can't afford it but the
people the responsible ones are supposed
to make up the difference The Working
Man you you're paying for it okay watch
this Medicare Medicare pay less than the
cost of caring for program beneficiaries
and annual shortfall of 57.8 billion
dollars let me continue this is very
important for you to know what's going
on here because you The Working Man
remember in a movie Sunny tells Robert
De Niro The Working Man is a sucker
right The Working Man is a sucker this
is what he was talking about we're
paying for everybody else that's saying
I'm not going to pay for it right this
is why the Working Man is so frustrated
in America today who is responsible
hospital
uncompensated care both free care and
care for which no payment is made up by
patients makes up about six percent of
the average hospitals cost most
hospitals receive no government
financial support at all to provide this
care though some hospitals owned by
local governments but not all public
hospitals receive tax subsidies from
state and local governments to help
offset some of the cause of care for
poor populations overall these payments
represent 10 cents per dollar of cost
privately even short patients and others
often make up the difference remember
Medicare all those guys they only make
up six percent of the cost the rest is
made up by us so somebody may be
watching to say Pat this is very
annoying no I know I'm also annoyed I
get I'm paying for it as well you are
too I'm not only paying for it I'm also
paying for it for a lot of different
people are having health insurance that
I'm paying for it's the cost I got it's
the benefit of you're giving COC what
benefit do you offer here's our health
insurance here's our health insurance so
I'm involved on both sides so what's the
solution Pat to me it's all
accountability because we have to sit
there and have the tough conversation
are we going to say yes to Medicare
Medicaid Social Security at all costs
even though everybody else takes the hit
and many go through bankruptcy is that
fair even though it hurts all the
Working Men it's like that man that was
talking to Elizabeth Warren he's like
wait a minute you're canceling College
loan on the people that didn't make
payments I busted my ass with two three
jobs to make sure my kids college
education was paid for I'm paying the
price me why am I paying I'm not rich
he's saying this rulers have been born
she doesn't have an answer form she's
got a smirk on her face because this
doesn't make sense and a lot of people
are going through this right now so it's
accountability in the life insurance
industry watch how the life insurance
industry Works versus Real Estate or
loans say I sell a house to Johnny I
sell them a million dollar house I get
them approved with a bank the bank says
I'll take this loan I sold a million
dollars the guy that's selling the house
he gets his money the equity had in the
house say you own 600 000 loan we sell a
four million 400 000 minus the
commission that check goes to the owner
of the house that sold it to the new
owner but the new owner who got the
house six months later says I don't want
to make the payments I'm okay I can't
afford it I don't want to make the
payments the other guy that owned the
house he doesn't care he already got us
checked the realtor I already got my
check I left I don't care you go collect
a check I don't need to collect a check
I don't have any accountability here
that guy has no accountability here the
bank is screwed and this man doesn't
want to make the rent how many times
does that happen in America he sits in
that house for 6 12 18 24 months some
states you can't even kick the guy out
he stayed there you can't kick me out
frustrating right you know how life
insurance Works here's how life
insurance works I sell the same person a
million dollar insurance policy it's 250
a month I get Advance a check let's just
say two three thousand dollars the
insurance company sends it to me advance
they send me the check six months down
the line Johnny stops making the
payments the insurance company calls me
said hey we haven't received the last
payment for the last six weeks I can't
say what do you want me to do go collect
I already got my money no no no if you
don't get Johnny to pay his next premium
you're gonna charge back how much
potentially the whole two thousand
dollars I give you or fifty percent let
me call Johnny I'm on top of let me I'll
drive to the guy's house to get the
payment because there's accountability
that's why I love life insurance because
there has to be accountability you can't
get away with it and I got my money I'm
good no you can't do that as long as we
can create a certain system of
accountability here we can't just say
hey Gen X gen Z Millennials screw you
guys you pay for it you can afford it
while everybody else they're just gonna
account for six percent of it dude no
I'm trying to have my own wife and kids
and family I'm just sending for private
school and doing this and doing and pay
my tax Center why are you doing this to
me that's kind of what's going on in the
health insurance the hospital the
Medicare the Medicaid so as much as we
can say well hospitals make so much
money they actually don't make a lot of
money margins are very small like the
restaurants they're just trying to get
money from somebody and who ends up
being a person that pays for the
hospital The Working Man
you and I we pay for it I don't think
it's cool I think it's tough
conversation I think if you share this
video with people that are of the age
they're going to watch this and they're
not going to be happy about it but I
don't want your vote I don't need your
vote I'm not trying to tell you I'm
running for office vote for me oh yeah
it's okay I'm not playing that game I
don't think that's right I think we all
got to do our part I think putting all
the punishment the next generation is an
unfair thing to do anyways if you agree
or disagree if I got you thinking you
got value out of this video give it a
thumbs up subscribe to the channel if
you like this video I got another video
I want you to watch it's on big Pharma
if you've not seen it wait till you see
the data on big Pharma click here to
watch the video on big Pharma take care
everybody bye-bye bye-bye
foreign
[Music]